CZ: Hello CZsWorld! I'd like to start by thanking everyone who sent me a message asking for my thoughts
on the Marina Joyce horror that's been going on over the last month.
I went ahead and watched her videos and I would definitely agree there are some creepy undertones there.
If you don't know, Marina Joyce is a British vlogger who became the center of a hashtag, #savemarinajoyce,
when she began to act strangely in her videos and people began to notice things like bruises,
people controlling her and apparent cries for help and encoded messages on her channel.
So I decided, why not get Marina herself on the line to discuss some of the weird stuff that I've noticed in her videos?
How you doing today Marina?
Marina: Hello!I just want to let you all know that I'm just fine,
and that I'm fine, and right now I'm in a really positive state of mind.
CZ: That's wonderful to hear Marina. It sounds like we may be having a little bit of connection issues here,
but I know there are a lot of people out there who are genuinely worried about you right now.
and I'm not personally of the belief that you are part of like a hostage situation or anything, but
I do see some questionable things going on in your videos. Now can--
Marina: I think that, sorry, I think that there are a lot of people out there who think that I have changed,
and they are leaving comments and saying that I have changed,
but I do want everyone to know that I have not changed and that I love you guys so much,
and that's not something I would ever do to my viewers is to change myself or to change my videos.
CZ: Alright, well, I'll tell you what.
I've got a big list of strange things that I took note of while watching your channel.
Can we just kind of go through and get your side of the story on some of these big ones
so you can finally put some of these questions behind you?
Marina: I would love to do that. Ask me anything!
CZ: So it seems like all the controversy began on your video, HOW TO LOSE WEIGHT.
A lot of people have been theorizing that your "captors" told you to make this video as a reaction
to the comments that you're getting thinner. So, what's your official statement on that?
Marina: So the reason that people actually have been leaving those comments is that actually,
I have lost weight after I became vegan.
And if anyone is thinking of becoming a vegan I would definitely recommend it,
and after I became vegan I became filled with all of this positive energy.
And now whenever I drink milk, I don't drink milk anymore--
CZ: Whoa, whoa. Hold up for one sec.
So, when you say "positive energy", you just mean you feel healthy?
Or... are you talking about some kind of spiritual energy?
Marina: I'm sorry, can you hold on for just one second? I just have to go do something for just one second.
CZ: Sure, take all the time you need.
*garbled background speech*
CZ: Marina? Huh.
*loud crash*
*garbled background speech*
CZ:What the...
*background cries*
Marina: OK, sorry about that.
CZ: Uhh, no worries. Is everything OK?
Marina: Yeah. I just had to turn off the telly in the other room.
CZ: Hey... Marina... Uhm....
Um, like I said earlier, I think some of the rumors flying around about you right now are pretty crazy.
But if there is, I don't know, SOMETHING, going on right now,
Well, you should just know that it's not too late to come forward and be direct about it.
Marina: It's nothing like that. I am fine. I swear. I'm fine.
CZ: OK. I'll take your word for it.
But just keep that in mind.
So I think we left off on the lose weight video.
It looks like you have some heavy bruising on your knuckles. Is there an explanation for that?
Marina: Yeah, I was going to the cupboard to retrieve a snack.
And I, what I did was by accident,
by accident I smashed my hand inside the door.
CZ: Alright. I guess that makes sense.
But what about the THINGS THAT GIRLS DO THAT GUYS HATE video?
Your knees are covered in bruises, and then in one of the skits we see your boyfriend grab your arm
in a spot where bruises appear in a later video.
Marina: Oh my gosh, no, no! I never even picked up on that.
No, I got those because, what had happened was, I was having a walk in the forest,
and I accidentally had a fall, in the forest, and that's how I got the bruises.
CZ: OK. I heard you mention something like that in the interview that you did with Philip DeFranco I believe.
But, I mean, I assume we're just talking about one fall that you had, and
some of these bruises do look pretty bad.
Marina: Like I mentioned before, it was after I went vegan, and so after I went vegan, I became
I began to feel much better positive energy, but one of the drawbacks is it is much more difficult to obtain vitamins,
so it was very easy for me to bruise.
CZ: Maybe this is just the meat-eater in me talking, but I thought you said you were much healthier as a vegan,
and actually I wrote down this quote, from one of your videos, that I found kind of odd.
But if you're getting bruises so easily from being a vegan, that just seems to be like a contradiction.
So, what's the point of continuing?
Marina: It really isn't the fact that I am vegan, because
what I want to do with my life is to save the animals,
because I love animals and I believe that all animals should be allowed to exist in our world.
But when I first became a vegan I didn't know how to get the proper nutrients,
So that, what would happen is I would get these bruises from very mundane tasks.
CZ: Alright, alright, fair enough. Let's jump to your next video: CURLING WITH A STRAIGHTENER.
There's a time-lapse sequence with music over it where I can see you talking where I can see you talking to someone.
Who is that?
Marina: I'm not really sure I remember, but it could be my mum, because my mum is amazing and I love her,
and she's very supportive of myself,
and what she will do, my mum will help me film my videos.
CZ: Obviously you have a very close relationship with your mother,
and I think that what has people concerned with this video,
and I'm not trying to be accusatory here,
is that you look very uncomfortable whenever you are looking or talking off camera.
And then the other thing is that there's no camera movement anywhere in the video,
so why would you even need help making it.
*garbled speech*
CZ: Marina, you're cutting out.
CZ: Can you hear me?
*garbled speech*
CZ: Marina?
CZ: Marina? Can you hear me now?
Marina: Oh, yes, I can hear you.
I do apologize because my internet can tend to be a bit rubbish at times.
CZ: No worries, just a couple more questions on that video.
In the background, and this is something that I've seen in a lot of your recent videos,
you can see these dinner plates, which has given people the ideas that you're locked up in a room, and
you're being given these meals everyday or something.
Again, I don't subscribe to the kidnapper theory, I think it's total crap, but what can you tell us about that?
Marina: Oh no, it's nothing like that.
I'm just very lazy about remembering to put my dish away.
CZ: At the end of the video you say I wish to speak with you in the comments,
but then you don't reply to any of the comments. What is that about?
Marina: I just get so many messages and I don't always get time to reply, but
I still love my viewers so much and I love them, they are so important to me!
CZ: But what I'm asking is, why would you specifically say, "I wish to speak with you",
if you know for a fact that you won't have time to reply to the comments?
Is this a cry for help of sorts?
Marina: No! I'm fine. I swear, I'm fine.
CZ: OK. Like I said, I believe you, but how do you explain what you said in DYING MY HAIR PINK, where you ask
the viewers for tips on healing yourself and tell everyone that you're really good at dealing with pain?
Marina: When I said, that, what I was referring to when I said that--
*glass shatters*
CZ: Marina? Everything OK?
Marina: Yes... Yes. Everything is fine. I am so happy!
CZ: Alright, um, well I know you're short on time so what do you say we skip to the big one?
DATE OUTFIT IDEAS?
Marina: I felt like you might be asking about that one actually.
CZ: There's so much questionable stuff going on in this video.
People off camera seem to be telling you what to do,
weird behaviour,
someone watching you through the window?
And then something keeps scaring your cat,
there's bruises,
and then there's this subliminal frame of you holding your head?
Where do we even begin with this?
Marina: Oh no...
CZ: What's that?
Marina: Please excuse me for one... one more second.
CZ: OK, Marina, what's going on over there?
*whispers*
CZ: Marina? Can you hear me?
Marina: No!
*object falling over*
CZ: My God...
*screaming and begging*
CZ: Marina? Marina, what's happening?!
*screaming*
CZ: Marina?
*screaming, crying, chaos, destruction*
*breathing*